I was a Tea Party candidate when I
became Governor it was popular opposed
every single corporate bailout we
possibly could we passed Tor reform we
passed one of the toughest illegal
immigration laws in the country we
passed pro-life bills we moved in
unemployment from 11% to 3% we took on
the unions and we took on Obama when it
came to the unions the Syrian refugees
and everything in
between I actually am really
impr that's not true standing in those
he is really hard true I mean they don't
I don't ask them what their they ask me
what my policies are and I tell them
what it is sometimes they agree with me
sometimes they don't some don't like how
tough Trump is like a schoolyard bully
who like ganging up on someone else with
his buddies behind him going like look
at that fat cow over there she's so fat
that doesn't matter that's who I am and
that's why conservative Grassroots group
in the country Americans for never
listen to she gives ex-wife to
me